of development or mass hysteria when
Michael Cohen pled guilty to lying to
Congress yesterday he would have thought
the conversation might kind of Center on
what that development meant for Cohen
you know the one who actually admitted
to lying but instead as is their track
record pundits and Democrats made a
Herculean leap to the president
suggesting some wild things in the
process he's got a good fate you know
case for collusion I mean if this were a
mafia investigation Trump be indited
under Rico no question about it he got
healthy on his congressional false
statement charges by coming clean today
he's a much more dangerous witness the
president is right to be nervous right
now because it appears that my time is
running out when it's become very clear
that the Trump campaign colluded with
the Russians in trying to subvert the
election but is that necessarily the
case last night we spoke to someone who
might know a thing or two about this I'm
just former whitewater deputy
independent counsel solve Eisenberg who
has fans of the show no is as honest as
they come watch all Cohen said is that I
I lied to Congress he didn't say that
President Trump helped me lie so there
could be all kinds of things that Muller
is keeping quiet from us that we don't
know about that Cohen has told him
that's possible but that's the realm of
speculation let's talk about reality and
reality is this is a nothing burger here
to make sense of it all Alan Dershowitz
professor emeritus at Harvard Law School
and author of the book the case against
impeaching Trump Allen is Trump shaking
in his boots over all this or it's all
right a big nothing burger well I think
it's a little bit of both look the
president should be concerned because
he's not going to get an objective
neutral nuanced report from Muller and
Muller is going to try to create a
narrative that takes all of these
perjury and lying charges and tries to
weave them into something against the
president but I think this all shows the
extraordinary weakness of the Muller
investigation
if you look at everything he's come up
with the vast majority of crimes are
things that happen after he became
special counsel not before he was
appointed to uncover crimes that had
already occurred
instead he helped ferment crimes by
creating these perjury traps having
people fall into them and then trying to
flip them as witnesses now you don't
have to believe me on that listen to
judge Ellis judge Ellis who was
presiding over the madam Florrick case
said that what Muller is doing looks
like he's trying to make these people
not only sing but perhaps under certain
circumstances even compose and it
doesn't show a strong prosecution case
when everybody who's been indicted
virtually is either indicted for lying
or indicted for unrelated financial
activities that have nothing to do with
the president at the moment it's hard to
know where's the beef where is the
actual substantive crimes that relate
directly to the relationship between the
campaign and Russia and also we have to
always remind ourselves collusion is not
a crime it is not a crime to use
materials stolen from Assange it is not
a crime to build a tower in Moscow
people I was hilarious to me to watch
some of the Chiron's blaring across the
lower third of screens on the other
cables last night you might as well have
thought that Donald Trump was on caught
on tape in Moscow like high-fiving Putin
saying good thanks for giving us all
those votes and you know name your state
but the way they were described even
that wouldn't be even that wouldn't be a
crime even Brad would not be a crime I
have to find something in your a statute
but you know there are political sins
but the difference being is sin in a
crime is the difference between a
democracy and tyranny well and this has
been the case from the beginning we've
had we've had all these little tidbits
of information that have trickled out
all these so-called bombshells Alan and
one after the other have kind of faded
away or been completely disproven and
Byron New York wrote an interesting
piece today I want to quote from it it's
it's titled remember prague in michael
cohen plea deal Muller says not
thing about key collusion allegation the
police shows that Muller closely
scrutinized everything Cohen told
Congress so if mother had ever intense
that Cohen's definitive denial of the of
the Prague story in the same document
was false it seems reasonable to
conclude that Muller would have charged
Cohen for it yet and the charges against
Cohen Muller said absolutely nothing
about Prague remember the Prague meeting
that was supposed to be another nail in
the coffin of Donald Trump and showing
real collusion no mention nothing but
it's so important to understand that you
have to look first to the statute books
and you can't look to these vague broad
statutes like obstruction of justice or
conspiracy you have to find specific Mac
mens rea actus rare criminal results and
it seems to me the molar fans in their
heats to try to find anything on Trump
are forgetting basic core civil
liberties and that is the ex post facto
Clause of the constant the due process
clause require that you find a specific
criminal act that's already prohibited
by the statute and then you have to
prove it beyond a reasonable doubt
it should never have been that's not
kicked off in the first place it was a
mistake from the beginning the way the
letter was written from Rosenstein
authorizing it all the way through to
today you called this from the very
beginning others did as well and I think
it's just it's once again it's like a
test case and why we have real
constitutional concerns about these
these prosecutors who have very little
supervision very little supervision over
what they're all and then the next and
the next issue is is Muller gonna try to
reproduce his report and have it made
public before the president's team has
an opportunity to review it respond to
it and issue their report simultaneously
basic fairness our adversary system all
requires that there can't be a
presumption that anything a prosecutor
says whether in an indictment or a
report is to be presumed true that would
undercut the presumption of innocence
you have to have the two reports issued
sign
Dainius li let the American public judge
whether or not the report rebutted and
answered really establishes crimes and
beatable offences or any of the other
things that Muller may be looking for
and I have a high level of suspicion
that in the end we're gonna see a lot of
indictments for perjury and lying a lot
of indictments for financial fraud
against other people but we're not going
to ultimately see any crimes directed
against the president United States look
that could change but at the moment it
doesn't appear that yeah we'll see what
else they might have in their quiver
professor I want to get your thoughts on
another huge story that we spent a lot
of time on this week you're on radio
earlier this week I devoted an entire
segment almost two segments to this
issue of anti-semitism rising in the
United States we've seen anti-semitic
acts rising increasing in Europe as well
but one of the first Muslim American
women elected to Congress this month of
course is now defending this fired CNN
commentator Marc Lamont Hill despite his
viciously anti-israel comments in a
speech he gave at the United Nations
congressman elect Rashida Slade
a democrat from michigan tweeted the
following quote calling out the
oppressive policies in israel advocating
for palestinians to be respected and for
Israelis and Palestinians alike to have
peace and freedom is not anti-semitic
CNN we all have a right to speak up
about injustice any and everywhere was
that what Marc Lamont Hill was doing no
of course not he was calling for
violence against Jewish civilians in
Israel he was saying don't follow Gandhi
don't follow Martin Luther King he was
praising terrorism against Jewish
civilians and there is now an
international definition of
anti-semitism and he'll fits right
within it you know I've debated him on
CNN and he is a bigot and he is an
anti-semite and he never should have
been on any network show he shouldn't be
teaching at a major university he is
very lovely anti-american anti-semitic
anti-israel and anti Western values in
general he's just a terrible terrible
human being
glorifying views of that
yeah well I know you're standing by them
well and and you know universities have
academic freedom on the other hand when
you have members of Congress standing by
him standing by Farrakhan some of the
same people stand by Farrakhan in fact
Hill stood by Farrakhan and and we have
many members today of the Black Caucus
who've stood by Farrakhan Farrakhan is
one of the biggest disseminators of
anti-semitism in the country today you
get you know CNN well because they get
away with it because the focus is on
only right-wing anti-semitism which is
condemned universally when you have that
showing in Pittsburgh everybody condemns
it but when you get anti-semitism coming
from the hard left like Hill and some of
these other people people don't condemn
it they praise it they stand up for it
can you imagine a professor making a
comparably anti black or anti-gay
statement no university would stand by
them so there's an absolute double
standard of tolerance for anti-semitism
anti Americanism anti Christianity anti
Western values it's a double standard
and it's unacceptable Thank You
professor it's great to have you on
tonight